[Música]
hola muchachos y muchachas yo soy víctor
medina y me dicen una nutria cuando digo
me dicen es porque literalmente así me
dice la gente así no es que me digo yo
yo me digo víctor aunque a veces me digo
mi amor porque bueno sino no se quiere
quién lo va a querer pero en fin
me dicen la nutria soy comediante soy
venezolano soy de san cristóbal y soy
tartamudo que de esto no tiene nada que
ver la charla a lo mejor mucha gente
crea que sí pero no solo que se los
tengo que decir porque como está un
evento por internet es para que ustedes
sepan que a veces que me voy a trancar
soy yo no toda la culpa la tiene el
router pero de que vengo a hablar en
esta charla para que me invitó a la
gente del señor tx para que me invitó
para resolver una pregunta que no está
carcomiendo desde hace muchos años a
venezuela y al mundo de donde es la
arepa los venezolanos decimos que es de
venezuela los colombianos dicen que es
de colombia el señor de la arepera dice
que es de quien se la pague de quien
realmente es la arepa es una pregunta
tan fuerte como esa pregunta de quien
vino primero el huevo o la gallina hay
muchas teorías si usted sigue la teoría
de la evolución le va a decir que
primero vino el huevo porque vino de un
animal un poco anterior a la gallina
saco el huevo y luego de ahí nace en la
primera
si usted sigue la teoría que sigo yo que
es que no me importa entonces lo que va
a decir es que no importa que no haya
sido primero pero los dos dentro de una
arepa va a saber bien eso es lo
importante pero esta pregunta esponja
como les dije es una pregunta que la
arepa siempre ha generado preguntas pero
nunca nos habíamos preguntado su origen
nos las comemos y ya generaba otro otro
tipo de preguntas que si es asada o
frita porque a la frita se le abrirá un
hueco en el centro algunos dicen que
para que se fría mejor otros dicen que
es para poder mirar así muchas preguntas
o la clásica pregunta que ha hecho que
familias se separen como los montesco y
los capuleto de la arepa que viene
primero el agua o la harina muchas
preguntas debe decirles esto si se lo va
decir de corazón yo era el equipo harina
muchachos pero los abandones ahora soy
del equipo agua porque es mucho mejor
primero porque la masa queda mejor queda
más homogénea todo queda bien esparcido
y segundo porque los dicen las
instrucciones y yo sé yo sé
leer las instrucciones de la harina no
es lo más venezolano del mundo pero ahí
están para que las necesite ahí está
pero que si queremos responder la
pregunta que de quién es la arepa cual
es origen necesitamos conocer la
historia de la arepa sus antecedentes
según fuertes investigaciones o muchas
investigaciones que se hicieron se sabe
que la arepa es pre colombinas o sea
antes de la colonización española lo que
quiere decir es que la arepa es más
muestra que nada ese estado aquí con
nosotros siempre de hecho se dice que la
arepa desde hace más de 2000 años
mientras jesús dividía el pan aquí los
indígenas estaban a más de que amase su
arepa y de dónde nace porque un indígena
se le ocurrió que querían sándwiches le
provocó un sándwich
no teníamos trigo para hacer pan y digo
bueno con maíz yo la hago porque al fin
y al cabo nos guste o no la arepa en
nuestro sándwich pero lo que no se puede
terminar con las investigaciones es
realmente de dónde fue primero sea si
fue en venezuela
colombia porque es más antes no existían
ni fronteras somos lo mismo éramos un
territorio reglas de hecho cuando se
crearon las fronteras éramos el mismo
país era la gran colombia muchas
investigaciones lo que sugieren es que
en paralelo al mismo tiempo empezaron a
hacer arepas esto quiere decir que la
arepa es menos nuestra no la arepa sigue
siendo nuestro desayuno nuestro almuerzo
la arepa es nuestra cena la arepa es
nuestra hoy estoy muy borracho y de
madrugada
me avergüenza llegar hacia la casa yo
mejor ambiente unas buenas 3 arepitas
antes de llegar la arepa es nuestra
aliada la arepa es nuestra amigos a si
la arepa está con nosotros quien está en
contra o sea la arepa lo es todo la
arepa es nuestro cable a tierra con
nuestras raíces con nuestro origen la
arepa es como la escena de ratatouille
cuando el crítico prueba la comida que
llega a sus recuerdos y los en su
infancia así es la arepa cuando la
comemos nos lleva a nuestra raíz lleva
tanto nuestros recuerdos que a veces
hasta se puede ir la luz que dice no ya
mucho recuerdo
y mucho recuerdo pero nace esa pregunta
y usted dice porque nació esta pregunta
que es nueva
muy sencillo explicar es porque
venezuela no era un país caracterizado
por migraciones masivas eso es nuevo y
de hace 10 años hacia acá muchos de
nosotros me incluyo nos hemos ido del
país buscando mejores oportunidades un
mejor futuro aprender nuevas cosas
ayudar a la familia en venezuela y ahora
estamos regados por el mundo somos una
diáspora y por más que lo traten a uno
bien por porque lo reciban increíble en
los países uno siempre se va a sentir
extranjero uno siempre se siente ajeno
hay días que usted se despierta hoy otro
acento y uno dice verdad que yo no soy
de aquí ahí es donde entra la arepa
la arepa es como lo que nos amarra los
que nos venimos los que nos une lo que
nos identifica
de hecho por eso es que nos enteramos
con la pelea con los colombianos porque
antes nosotros nos comíamos la arepa ya
al salir y al migrar es que nos dimos
cuenta que los colombianos dijeron no
pero es que esas niñas también y nos yo
entiendo la indignación porque para
nosotros es como que hasta eso nos van a
quitar o sea con todos los que nos han
quitado durante estos años con todo lo
que hemos sufrido que a lo único que nos
aferramos es una arepa hasta eso nos van
a quitar sentimos que es como que nos
están pateando mientras nos arrastramos
en el suelo pero que hay entiendo es un
sentimiento que hay que hay que dejar
atrás les voy a contar un es una
historia que no tiene mucho que ver con
arepas de hecho debió haber tenido mucha
más arepa de las que tuvo pero creo que
enfoca un poco más la idea de la arepa a
los que les quiero decir yo emigré de
venezuela en el 2017 en el año 2017 un
año llenos de protestas de problemas
políticos de bombas lagrimógenas de todo
eso fue yo comía la pasta aderezada con
un bello sabor a bomba lacrimógena en
ese año yo prácticamente no puedo
trabajar porque los teatros estaban
cerradas las calles están paralizadas si
lograba tener un show no lo podía
promocionar mucho en las redes porque no
es momento para chiste cifras que por
cierto venezuela tiene como 15 años que
en el momento para existe citó si
venezuela tiene como 15 años diciendo
que el país está como está porque hacen
un chistecito de todo cuando yo creía
que el país estaba como estaba era por
20 años de corrupción sin parar pero
bueno cada quien puede tener su opinión
al respecto
entonces yo ese año de verdad tuve muy
poco trabajo tuve muy pocos problemas
del estrés y la ansiedad de las
protestas me salió una alergia en la
cara muchachos que yo me sentía un señor
como en 75 años y yo digo que por el
bien de mi carrera y de mi persona y de
mi vida yo creo que me tengo que ir del
país me fui a méxico y la verdad cuando
me fui a méxico me fui muy desencantado
de venezuela yo era de esos que no
quería saber nada de venezuela ni los
venezolanos de los que sí que si veo a
alguien con una gorra tricolor me cambio
hacer algo yo no quiero ver a esta gente
no me quiero juntar con esta gente y en
méxico me enfoqué en los mexicanos me
dice a mí
el comediante mexicanos hice mucho yo
para público mexicano que me
promocionada porque no quería que
llegaran los venezolanos al show porque
quería agarrar un público nuevo quería
como resetearme mejor me y me fue bien
en médico tuve muchas oportunidades hice
muchas relaciones públicas logré tener
muchos shows pero ya cuando tenía un año
en méxico por problemas migratorios me
recordaron a la fuerza que yo no era de
ese país me cachetearon y no pude
regresar a mexico yo quedé como en un
limbo porque no podía regresar a méxico
que aunque estaba creando mi nueva vida
y no podía regresar a venezuela porque
sentía que si regresaba en eso de la era
una derrota como que había perdido que
tenía que volver a lo que hui entonces
quedé como en un limbo de hecho que
bogotá como un mes mientras veía qué
hacer mientras resolvía los problemas
legales de verdad de hecho conocí la
verdadera depresión perdí mucho peso me
sentía triste tenía sueño todo el tiempo
descubrí que si estaba deprimido en
realidad y lo que antes había sentido
era que había escuchado muchas canciones
de my chemical romance
de verdad sufrí y al mes más por
necesidad que por gusto decía ser un
show tengo que hacer un show porque
necesito hacer dinero empecé a preguntar
a teatros a bares todo eso no les
importaba ni quién era yo ni qué había
hecho me decían no no no no no no no por
suerte un amigo me contactó con un bar
un bar pequeño en el que me dijo que
íbamos a dar una fecha me dieron un
lunes en la noche para los que saben de
teatros y de movida nocturna los lunes
en la noche es como la peor fecha del
mundo es la peor y además yo la pedí un
miércoles me la dieron para el siguiente
lunes o sea menos de una semana de
publicidad que era obvio que era que
tenían esa fecha y abierta y era un buen
hotel agarre
yo dije ok voy a hacer mi show no
importa las personas que lleguen
van a llegar y ese dinero me va a servir
por lo menos para taxi de ida y devenida
pongo la promoción y el mismo día se
agotó muchacho a mi me volvió el alma al
cuerpo yo me sentí como otra vez querido
diga la verdad
verdad que hay gente que le gusta lo que
hago todo fue increíble y cuando hice el
show me pareció una locura llegué estoy
en bogotá con un yo hago también una
semana y obviamente el 95% de las
personas que están de ahí eran
venezolanos
yo dije claro esto es la arepa ellos
eran la arepa para mí y yo era la arepa
para ellos era como una conexión con lo
que son no sentirse ajenos sentirse
identificados decían él es como yo y yo
soy como ellos aunque estemos en otro
lugar geográfico ese momento todos
sabíamos que era la arepa me parece
increíble y de hecho el show que salió
de la nada por pura necesidad se
convirtió en tres shows agotados
increíble y yo cambié mi forma de ver yo
dije increíble que a la venezolanidad
que le estaba yendo
es la que me terminó salvando
literalmente me terminó llevando una
arepa a la boca de verdad fue como una
maravilla fue me cambio y ahora yo
siento que hay que seguir más los
consejos de la arepa aprender más de la
arepa porque es una locura querer
agarrarlo para nosotros y es que la
arepa es nuestra la arepa nuestra y si
es muy bueno que la reconozcamos como
nuestra que representa nuestras raíces
pero hay que seguir más el ejemplo de la
arepa en lugar de cerrarnos abrirnos a
cualquier cultura a cualquier cosa nueva
sea si usted una arepa le mete carne al
pastor que es mexicana en la arepa qué
increíble si usted agarra un asado
argentino y se lo meten arepa que
increíble si te agarran chistorra y se
la mete a una arepa que increíble existe
agarra huevos de codorniz y se los mete
a una arepa le va a dar una cantidad de
gas es increíble pero va a quedar muy
buena igual si usted no tiene nada que
meterle y le mete mantequilla igual la
arepa
ella no se cierra ella no es que dice
venezuela es el mejor país del mundo y
no quiero saber más de nada ella se abre
dice ok venezuela es un país muy bueno
pero voy a ver que hay más por ella
afuera para nutrirme porque una arepa
rellena siempre es mejor muchachos y lo
importante que hay que aprender aquí es
que la arepa sin importar de qué esté
rellena siempre va a ser una arepa
listo que o bien bueno entonces vamos a
grabar la que la que era entonces
women en toda la calle
esa broma siento ese final